ils contribuent au développement de
l'informatique du futur ingénieur
industriel chercheurs ont participé à
cette matinée des changes
organisé par le pôle d'innovation
systématique parmi eux georges raymond
see you de la start-up pascal son
activité le développement d'un
processeur informatique quantique cd des
processeurs de nouvelle génération qui
vont permettre de surmonter les limites
de nos processeurs actuels les dd banque
lance des fonds font des calculs toute
la nuit pour optimiser leurs pleurs lors
leur placement en fait un pur pour gérer
le risque et donc c'est des calculs qui
prennent du temps qu'ils prennent toutes
les nuits l'ordinateur quantique la
possibilité d'accélérer les calculs
informatiques dans tous les domaines
notamment la cybersécurité on sait
détecter de façon certaine s'il ya une
intrusion dans les communications par
exemple et donc de certifier l'intégrité
de ce qu'on reçoit notamment les clés
qui se permet de chiffrer les
informations et de protéger ses
informations
cette technologie de rupture pose des
questions sur la sécurité informatique
pour parer à ces dangers
la start-up crypto next développe des
solutions donc le problème c'est qu'il
ya certains problèmes dont on n'a pas
envie qu'il soit résolu plus rapidement
et en particulier ceux qui sont qui
permettent de garantir la sécurité de
toutes les communications
nous ce qu'on propose c'est une nouvelle
génération de systèmes de sécurité de
cryptographie qui sont résistants à
l'ordinateur quantique a deux qui vont
permettre en fait de se préserver de
cette menace
le cantique un secteur en développement
au sein de l'université paris saclay un
centre des sciences et technologies
quantiques baptisé quantum a été lancée
cette année pour rassembler les acteurs
de la recherche dans ce domaine